das topspiel des 21 spieltags zwischen
dem fc bayern und rb leipzig bietet den
10.000 fans in der arena ein echtes
spektakel mit der ersten gelegenheit
schlagen die münchner eiskalt zu thomas
müller bringt dem rekordmeister nach
zwölf minuten in führung
rb aber zeigt sich unbeeindruckt spielt
mutig nach vorne und kommt durch silva
nach einer knappen halben stunde zum
ausgleich
kurz vor der pause bringt dann robert
lewandowski mit seinem 24 saisontreffer
die gastgeber wieder in führung das
ex-team von julian nagelsmann aber
kämpft sich erneut zurück im kongo nach
traumpass von lime eine 53 minute mit
dem ausgleich zum 2 2 am ende leistet
sich rb aber zu viele fehler joshua die
all trifft ins eigene tor der
siegtreffer für die bayern in der 58
minute für manuel neuer der 310
bundesliga-sieg damit hat er zu oliver
kahn aufgeschlossen
borussia dortmunds im verfolgerduell
gegen bayer leverkusen also unter
zugzwang
damit der rückstand auf den
spitzenreiter nicht auf neun punkte
anwächst der start in die partie für den
bvb allerdings katastrophal vogelwild es
defensivverhalten endet in einem
slapstick eigentor von manuela kann sie
nach zehn minuten
auf der anderen seite aber auch die
leverkusener zunächst unglücklich den
freistoß von brandt lenkt jeremy
frimpongs ins eigene netz das eins zu
eins in der 16 minute bayer aber zeigt
sich unbeeindruckt kontert lehrbuchmäßig
und geht erneut in führung nach 20
minuten ist florian würz der torschütze
die gastgeber hängen jetzt in den seilen
robert andere ich erhöht nach einer
knappen halben stunde per traum freistoß
auf 3 zu 1 für die werkself statt einer
dortmunder aufholjagd in halbzeit zwei
führt die mannschaft von marco rose
vorgeführt jonathan ta spektakulär zum 4
2 1 nach 53 minuten diaby setzt drei
minuten vor schluss noch einen drauf
dortmund erlebt im eigenen stadion ein
debakel
daran ändert auch der treffer des
eingewechselten stefan tigges sekunden
vor dem ende zum 2 zu fünft nichts mehr
der bvb verliert die bayern aus den
augen leverkusen rückt auf fünf punkte
an die dorte daran
der erste fc köln muss gegen den sc
freiburg ohne den ancona erkrankten
cheftrainer steffen baumgart auskommen
sein assistent andré pawlak vertritt ihn
und der sieht ein gutes spiel seiner
mannschaft mit dem vorläufigen höhepunkt
in der 23 minute anthony modeste zur
verdienten 1 0 führung
nur wenige minuten nach dem
seitenwechsel jubeln dann die freiburger
allerdings kurz denn das tor vom
eingewechselten joel einem
schiedsrichter felix brych wieder zurück
weil schlotterbeck im sichtfeld von fcp
besteht so feiern die kölner einen
knappen aber verdienten sieg
[Applaus]
der fc augsburg will sich zu hause gegen
union berlin luft im tabellenkeller
verschaffen und die mannschaft von
markus weinzierl präsentiert sich in der
anfangsphase hellwach und lauert auf die
fehler der köpenicker torwart luthe
gegen seinen ex-club mit dem schlechten
pass michael gregor iec bedankt sich
nach 16 minuten mit der führung in
halbzeit zwei kommt union zwar besser
ins spiel es sind aber die augsburger
die eiskalt zuschlagen andré hahn per
traumtor in der 59 minute machte den
vierten heimsieg in dieser spielzeit für
den fcr perfekt
im südwest derby zwischen mainz 05 und
1899 hoffenheim beweisen die gastgeber
abermals ihre heimstärke in dieser
saison ist dauert allerdings bis zur
schlussphase ehe die mainzer die weichen
auf sieg stellen der eingewechselte
liebrecht in der 79 minute den bann
nur vier minuten später fällt dann nach
einem handelfmeter die entscheidung
kapitän ihr café verwandelt sicher und
sorgt dafür dass hoffenheim nach der
dritten liga niederlage hintereinander
in der tabelle weiter abrutscht
der vfb stuttgart steckt nach fünf
spielen ohne eigenen treffer mitten im
abstiegskampf und gerät auch im
heimspiel gegen eintracht frankfurt
zunächst in rückstand gewann dicker mit
der führung für die gäste nach gerade
mal sieben minuten
nach einer halben stunde kommt der vfb
dann in tritt und er spielt sich gute
chancen eine davon nutzt waldemar anton
in der 42 minute durststrecke beendet
halbzeit zwei beginnt mit einem schock
für die gastgeber der eingewechselte
rostig mit der erneuten führung für die
eintracht in der 47 minute der vfb aber
beweist moral der lange verletzte sasa
karadzic mit seinem ersten saisontor 2
zu 270 minuten
doch den schwaben fehlt in dieser
saisonphase auch ein wenig das glück
denn lustig macht seinen doppelpack
perfekt der schuss in der 77 minute aber
entscheidend abgefälscht die niederlage
verschärft die stuttgarter krise
spiel 1 für borussia mönchengladbach
nach der ära max eberl die fohlen zu
gast bei arminia bielefeld geraten schon
früh unter druck jannis ära bringt die
hausherren nach 17 minuten in führung zu
diesem zeitpunkt auch verdient
gladbach kann in der folge den druck
erhöhen und belohnt sich dafür player
mit dem ausgleich nach 38 minuten nach
schöner vorarbeit von hofmann zu mehr
bringt es die borussia aber nicht und
verpasst damit einen befreiungsschlag
tayfun korkut und thomas reis sehen ein
spannendes spiel ihrer teams im berliner
olympiastadion die hertha vor allem nach
standards gefährlich nach 23 minuten
köpfte full deal seine mannschaft in
führung
der zweite treffer der berliner liegt in
der luft ist sind aber die bochumer die
nach der pause erfolgreich sind
sebastian polter gerade mal drei minuten
in der partie mit dem ausgleich in der
48 minute so einführt bochum einen punkt
aus der hauptstadt
max kruse ist zurück beim vfl wolfsburg
und soll dabei helfen dass die wölfe in
der bundesliga bleiben dafür ist ein
sieg gegen schlusslicht greuther fürth
schon fast pflicht und die gastgeber
erwischten den besseren start und lägen
vor asta franks mit dem 1 0 nach sieben
minuten
danach kommt vom vfl aber viel zu wenig
kurz vor der pause per strafstoß zum
ausgleich das spiel plötzlich wieder
offen nach dem seitenwechsel tritt das
team von florian cove eltern aber
dominanter auf franks nutzt den fehler
von fürths torwart borchert zur führung
49 minute
der freistoß von maximilian arnold noch
abgefälscht in der 70 minute sorgt dann
für die entscheidung das 3 zu 1
maximilian philipp setz in der
schlussphase noch einen drauf das 4 2 1
in der 75 minute der schlusspunkt in
einer am ende einseitigen partie es ist
der erste sieg für die wolfsburger seit
dem 6 november des vergangenen jahres
die ergebnisse des 21 spieltags im
überblick die bayern setzten sich im top
spiel gegen leipzig durch leverkusen und
wolfsburg feiern jeweils kantersiege
augsburg mit einem wichtigen heimsieg
gegen union berlin in
der tabelle bauen die bayern ihren
vorsprung auf verfolger dortmund auf
neun punkte aus köln zieht an leipzig
und hoffenheim vorbei und erobert sich
einen internationalen platz in der
unteren tabellenhälfte springt wolfsburg
von 15 auf 12 stuttgart hat jetzt schon
vier punkte rückstand auf den
relegationsplatz
[Musik]